[Musica]
da poco meno di un mese sono cominciate
le scuole voi ve lo ricordate uno dei
vostri primi giorni di scuola quando si
rincontrano gli amici ci si racconta di
come sono state le vacanze delle belle
giornate no eppure sono sicuro che
ognuno di noi indipendentemente alla
generazione che sia la mia che sia la
vostra quella dei nostri figli se le
avete ognuno di noi almeno una volta ha
pensato a questo
beh in fondo chi ci può dar torto tre
mesi di assoluta libertà però con lo
spauracchio con il fantasma di settembre
che ritorna con la scuola che ritorna e
quando ritorna giu compiti verifiche
studio che palle e allora perché esiste
la scuola è un obbligo
questo non significa che dobbiamo
abolire la scuola ci mancherebbe altro
però perché esiste veramente la scuola
normalmente le risposte che diamo
potrebbero essere queste per educare i
giovani a stare nella società per
crescerli come lavoratori per crescerli
come persone quante volte glielo abbiamo
detto questo ai ragazzi ai giovani un
milione fosse un miliardo ma loro ci
credono
vi faccio un esempio quante volte ci
siamo trovati tutti quanti di fronte a
quel mattone di storia di filosofia di
letteratura ad andare la vita e pensare
quando mai mi servirà ecco allora che
cosa facevamo cercando magari una
distrazione guardavamo accendevamo la tv
o quando eravamo più piccoli magari
andavamo a giocare con gli amici o
quando eravamo più grandicelli
chiudevamo il libro ci vestivamo e
magari uscivamo ecco la fatica che noi
facevamo nel chiudere il libro né
investirci nell uscire con gli amici i
giovani di oggi l'hanno minimizzata in
un solo movimento
ecco questo non è solo il simbolo
moderno della socialità non voglio
parlare di quest'oggi
questo strumento è in grado di reperire
qualsiasi informazione dello scibile
umano semplicemente facendo una ricerca
su google ma più che altro è in grado di
riprodurre qualcosa che i libri non
saranno mai
in grado di fare che sono immagini in
movimento i video per cui realtà la
prima causa di distrazione dei giovani
al giorno d'oggi grazie a questo e
youtube youtube conta circa 2 miliardi
di utenti attivi ogni mese in rapida
ascesa più di un miliardo di ore di
video viste al giorno sono tante e in
un'era dove l'informazione è diventata
la moneta principale dove l'accesso
veloce alle informazioni è diventata una
priorità
con la scusa di dare ai giovani uno
strumento in grado di reperire
informazioni di fatto noi gli abbiamo
dato la prima causa di distrazione
eppure l'obbligo di studiare esiste
ancora
eppure siamo ancora lì di fronte a quel
libro ma quel tomo di storia di
letteratura di geologia ad andare la
vita intera dannare i professori perché
mi fanno studiare una cosa che
probabilmente la troverai
tranquillamente su internet quando mi
serve se mai mi servirà e allora ecco
che torna il tema del a cosa mi serve
oggi viviamo bene tra non oggi negli
ultimi anni ormai in un clima di scarso
lavoro soprattutto a livello giovanile
lo leggiamo tutti i giorni sui giornali
lo ascoltiamo alla radio e in più
serpeggia tra i giovani quella
sensazione che per ottenere un lavoro
decente oggi forse non ti serve studiare
ti bastano due cose fortuna e le giuste
raccomandazioni che studiare allora
magari non ti serve anzi che ti
basterebbe imparare quelle quattro cose
che ti servono per immediati un lavoro
decente magari non ambizioso ma che ti
porti a casa il pane e il resto lo puoi
trovare tranquillamente su internet
stiamo vivendo in un periodo di
fortissima disillusione nei confronti
dello studio da entrambi i lati
il lato dei giovani
che vede nella scuola un sistema antico
vecchio sul passato preistorico che non
ti prepara la vita vera ma anche dal
lato degli adulti dai genitori che
vedono sempre con più preoccupazione il
fatto di voler trovare un lavoro anche
di nuovo non ambizioso ai propri figli
ecco quindi che crollano le iscrizioni
all'università
ecco che si alza il tasso di abbandono
scolastico e non solamente per i ragazzi
anche in giovane età anche ai bambini
ci preoccupiamo di volergli dare un
lavoro che già gli insegniamo i lavori
del futuro
ecco che i bambini cominciano imparare
il cinese
ora programmazione a discapito di
materie come la geografia che sta
lentamente scomparendo dalle scuole e
quindi mi sembra che l'unico motivo per
il quale esiste al giorno d'oggi la
scuola sia solo questo noi stiamo
crescendo dei lavoratori prima che delle
persone ea tre scegli come persone a
dargli una cultura ci sta pensando
internet con i suoi video con i suoi
astag ma anche con le sue notizie false
e quindi il tema che mi piacerebbe che
ci portassimo caso tutti quanti e che
magari ne discutessimo con i nostri
figli con i giovani è come possiamo
cambiare l'insegnamento per fare in modo
che i giovani si possano riallacciare
alla cultura già in realtà sbagliamo
perché noi non dobbiamo cambiare le
materie che consideriamo vecchie di
nuovo la geografia la letteratura e
latino o la chimica vanno bene così
vi faccio un esempio oggi soprattutto
negli ultimi tempi li avrete sentito
viviamo in un clima di odio di divisione
sociale di suprematismo se noi non
studiassimo la storia
ve lo ricordate l'ultima volta cosa è
successo dopo un clima di odio di
divisione sociale del suprematismo no le
materie vecchie vanno bene così
noi dobbiamo adeguare l'insegnamento per
fare in modo che i giovani possono
ritornare alla cultura e lo dobbiamo
fare in realtà con quello che ci ha
contraddistinto negli ultimi 20 anni e
che ha contraddistinto la crescita dei
giovani che è la tecnologia digitale
oggi vorrei portarvi una testimonianza
una visione che abbiamo avuto nella
scuola dove lavoro di quello che
potrebbe essere una lezione nel futuro
lo abbiamo chiamato oro come il ponte
gli ologrammi avete presente
l'enterprise l'astronave di star trek
qualcuno probabilmente l'ha visto stata
è vero ok quel ponte gli ologrammi ci si
poteva entrare e cambiava a seconda di
quello che si voleva si poteva essere
alle maldive su un altro pianeta quello
che si voleva
ecco olo dec per noi è una classe in
realtà virtuale dove ogni studente al
proprio viso re ed è in grado di
assistere a delle lezioni di materie
normali come l'astronomia come la
chimica le scienze ma anche alla storia
e la geografia aumentate attraverso
l'animazione 3d
oltretutto i ragazzi possono vedersi
all'interno dello spazio virtuale e
possono vedere le loro mani quindi
possono interagire con gli oggetti 3d
ecco che quindi noi non stiamo andando a
cambiare cosa dobbiamo raccontare ai ai
giovani stiamo aggiornando il come lo
vogliamo raccontare in realtà
utilizziamo una tecnologia che è molto
più sulle loro corde un sistema di
insegnamento che è basato su quello che
loro normalmente vedono ogni giorno che
sono le immagini in movimento
oggi avevamo pensato di portare
una demo portarvi una demo di olo delle
grazie alle tecnologie di questa sala
sarebbe stato l'effetto wow di questo
speech purtroppo qualche giorno fa la
direzione del m 9 ci ha detto che questa
sala non sarebbe più stata in grado di
supportare questo tipo di demo per cui
io innanzitutto vi faccio le mie più
profonde scuse e vi chiedo di fidarvi
semplicemente delle immagini che avete
visto nella mia parola sul fatto che
questa tecnologia è veramente
incredibile e invitarvi qualora lo
vogliate a venirla a provare
direttamente a big rocca lì almeno i
visori funzionano o l'udc è una
sperimentazione ancora non abbiamo la
pretesa la presunzione che diventi la
scuola del futuro ci piacerebbe però
poterle integrare a quello che è un
sistema di lezioni che esiste già come
un laboratorio come laboratorio di arte
o lavoratore di scienze che già esistono
delle scuole
immaginatevi un ora di astronomia un'ora
di geografie un'ora di storia o un'ora
di chimica passata un'ora la settimana
passata all'interno di olio
sarebbe incredibile anche perché è
scientificamente provato che quando uno
studente a che fare con una lezione di
tipo interattivo quindi può interagire
anche con le mani le sinapsi del
cervello si attivano molto di più quindi
una lezione di tipo interattivo in
questo modo è molto molto più efficace
noi dobbiamo ricominciare o meglio
dobbiamo cominciare a usare la
tecnologia per riportare gli studenti a
a innamorarsi di nuovo della cultura e
dobbiamo insegnarle a utilizzare le
tecnologie che loro già hanno youtube
che sembrava denigrazione prima in mezzo
a tanta porcheria un sacco di video
bellissimi estremamente istruttivi it
had per primi
la programmazione va bene insegnare ai
bambini ma che abbia uno scopo che gli
insegni come ragiona logicamente un
computer per fare in modo che loro
possano imparare a ragionare ea livello
critico a livello logico ma soprattutto
dobbiamo cercare di insegnare a sognare
ai nostri figli a sognare quello le
persone che vorrebbero essere da grandi
e lo dobbiamo fare appunto con la
tecnologia dobbiamo farli reinnamorare
della cultura perché solo la cultura gli
farà crescere come persone
un recente studio di leggo su un
campione di circa 3.000 bambini ha
riportato che alla domanda cosa vorresti
fare da grande più di un terzo di loro
ha detto che vorrebbe fare lo youtuber
invece che l'astronauta questa cosa è
agghiacciante
in un momento come questo dove stiamo
per affrontare
uno dei cambiamenti climatici più
catastrofici della nostra storia
noi non abbiamo bisogno di youtuber noi
abbiamo bisogno di scienziati
abbiamo bisogno di medici abbiamo
bisogno di architetti abbiamo bisogno di
politici giusti abbiamo bisogno di tutti
quegli eroi che grazie alla loro cultura
e al loro sapere possono rimediare agli
errori del passato e cercare di fare
qualcosa per curare questo pianeta o se
non ce la possono fare è trovare una
soluzione per abbandonarlo per cui si
abbiamo bisogno di astronauti io mi
auguro che al prossimo oggi primo giorno
di scuola possiamo ricordare tutti
quanti ai nostri giovani ai nostri figli
il perché stanno andando a scuola il
perché studiano ricordiamo gli di
sognare di sognare un futuro migliore o
essere ispirati da altri sognatori e
studiare tanto
farsi una cultura e poter effettivamente
realizzare quei sogni essere nel mezzo
tra queste due cose in questo momento
non ne vale veramente la pena
[Applauso]
[Musica]